as you know and as you mentioned in your
article
heather and i have been
libeled by wikipedia pages that
ostensibly describe our role in the
world from
relatively early
in the pandemic at least
you know early in the
public health campaigns against
repurposed drugs and for
these uh transfection agents which we
are calling vaccines for some reason
but in any case
i have not known
the effect of having one's wikipedia
page accuse
you of spreading misinformation
is huge and i would also point out quite
unmeasurable
right and just to to lay this out from
my personal perspective before we get to
uh what's happened to you and what you
discovered about what's going on at
wikipedia
youtube demonetized darkhorse
the sword that people see sticking
through the counter behind me signifies
the sort of damocles hanging over the
podcast
and
basically that in the space of one hour
they demonetized both our channels and
knocked out more than half of our family
income
i believe they probably were going to
shut down the channel and i think i
probably got in the way of that by
talking about this on joe rogan's
program which alerted people to the
hazard of censorship at uh at youtube
um but in any case
this demonetization by youtube of course
puts us in the predicament of having to
keep a roof over our children's heads
and and all of those things
um in other ways
now what are those other ways for people
you know we were uh professors that was
a very secure we thought
form of income at the point that
madness drove us from our professions we
generated accidentally this
alternative way of feeding our family it
worked well then youtube with the you
know a couple of
a couple of moves got in the way
um
the next
way to fund is to go through our viewers
who
youtube has
uh behind the scenes influence over who
gets to see the channel how many of them
there are etc who gets unsubscribed
without taking any action
but most importantly we can seek
advertisers to sponsor the podcast but
for an advertiser trying to decide what
to do to
to gain
some exposure for their product
they're of course going to go to our
wikipedia pages and to have our
wikipedia pages accuse us of being
dangerous spreaders of
misinformation
therefore obviously endangering human
lives that's not something advertisers
want to mess with so the question of
given
a
private unaccountable non-transparent
system at youtube combined with a out of
control
mechanism at wikipedia the ability to
disrupt somebody's capacity to earn
is staggering
yeah right and that's before we get to
just the simple fact of the reputational
damage and what effect that has on
interacting with people in the world
so all right um what did you find what
happened to you and what did you find
about what's going on at wikipedia yeah
so what happened to me was that um
i
was
uh i i was about to give evidence in a
fun life in one of the i think it's it's
claimed to be the first
um case of
uh
of
the first case brought against a
government a national government
on covet mandates which has actually got
to cause in jakarta indonesia and i was
an expert brought in as an expert
witness on the data
supporting the vaccine efficacy and
safety right so i was
um
uh
scheduled to give this evidence and
about
a week before
i was going to give the evidence the
lawyers on outside said
do you realize that
the um
wikipedia is saying this has got you
down as under covert 19 misinformation
and it had a statement there which i
don't know if i should maybe um
i could read out what it was it's it's
basically says um
in march 2021
so it says under the heading covid19
this information in march
2021 fenton was one of several
economists who put their name to a
document seeking to persuade the british
government not to pass covet 19
legislation blah blah blah
um unless then quotes people saying it
was ridiculous um the vaccines in
question hadn't established safety
profile
we showed a blatant disregard for the
facts irresponsible in the extreme now
whether or not
let's put aside what whether um
the claims that they said we made were
true or not i never signed that was
simply that whole thing was was false it
was it was it was based on a highly
misleading
times article
that had been published in in march uh
2021
um by a guy by theirs there's the
science editor called uh tom whipple
and
it was easy i say this this this idea
that i'd signed this document claiming
that the the that it said it actually
said that the vaccines they claimed that
the um the vaccines were causing the uh
the second that the vaccines were
causing the second wave of deaths which
was happening at the time
and that i'd signed the document
basically presented it you know
convincing the uh government legislation
no such thing happened i never signed
there was no such thing happen what it
was based on was this misleading report
as follows right i happen to be one of
quite a large number of people who are
on this heart group which is basically a
group
i can't remember where it stands it's a
group which has right from the beginning
attempted to
put
let's say
a more rational narrative on that you
know look at the you know look at the
covert data more rational viewpoint than
what we're being presented by the
governments you know people would call
us a group of skeptics i'd say but it's
you know very you know we've got you
know there's a broad you know quite a
cross-section of people there you know
we've got very very senior clinicians
pathologists you know uh data scientists
etc psychologists that you know a whole
group of people and what happened was
that actually i didn't even really i
didn't even know about this because it's
not like we somehow sit around
discussing everything you know that
we're gonna do
um and i'm not one of the leaders i'm
not one of this sort of the uh the
organizer anything like that but
basically put they put out just a
compendium of papers a compendium of
nine i think it was 13 or whatever
um over a dozen papers
which covered various things right one
of which one of which was a paper by um
a statistician called joel smalley where
he simply raised he'd simply shown
that there appeared to be a spike in
the deaths
it's a spike in all cause mortality
after the vaccine program was rolled out
and he simply raised the issue saying
well look this needs to be this is
saying which you need to you need to
look at so there was one paper
not off buddy i was not the author of
any paper in that report so my name this
idea that i signed a document
you know this is is is simply an
incredible lie
my name was simply listed on the inside
cover
as one of the men one of the many dozens
of members of heart
right and they translated that into
that to me signing a document which was
which which was saying that the vaccines
were causing the second wave
of injuries so that was the that's the
basis of what the the
and and this you know the statement that
was in wikipedia
about me which i i mean i was i didn't i
hadn't looked at my wikipedia entry for
for years for years it's not right i
didn't didn't it's not something i
thought about but then to be told just
before you're going to give evidence you
know as an expert witness and a chaos
that wikipedia is saying that you're a
spread of misinformation
right and you're claiming wrongly
against all all the evidence that you
know that the vaccines are causing these
mass deaths which you know was never
saying anyway
and even the article was never saying
that that was the thing the article
never said it at all
um
it was just ridiculous now as it so
happens
from the
the lawyers in the case kind of like
managed
to turn this i did i mean i didn't do
anything about it i thought
i don't edit
right what can you
i can't get i'm looking i'm not going to
get people to try and go in edit i
didn't link and the lawyers were sort of
quite comfortable with it because they
wanted to actually show
at the beginning of my evidence that
this was an example
of what happens to people who actually
do present a counter narrative but they
get these liars about them uh spread on
on on wikipedia
so hold on i i have to interrupt you
here and just make one point um
people who have viewed a lot of
dark horse
will remember that heather and i on one
of our live streams
covered a paper
by christine
benn
in which it did show
that there is a
an increase in all cause mortality for
people who got the mrna-based vaccines
the reverse is true there is a slight
benefit to the dna based adenovectored
vaccines
but i just want to point out that not
only were you
libeled and
a simple lie told about you you having
signed a document that you did not sign
but the content wasn't misinformation
exactly i mean that's a separate exactly
that's
you know a lot of the things that that
were actually said there of course yeah
we've also done work on all calls
looking at all calls mortality after um
the vaccination and
what we can certainly conclude is that
there are certainly no there is
certainly no reduction in all calls
mortality and the vaccinated compared
with the unvaccinated so well i would
also say
i would also point out as long as we're
here
that
this is a
measure
in which the mortality
is
likely to go up with time in other words
absolutely vaccines have only existed
for a year and a half and so what we're
looking at is that so far we've seen an
increase in deaths but to the extent
that people might die five years ten
years after these vaccinations as a
result of some interference with their
normal physiology then those numbers
would climb so
we can simply say that there is already
evidence of an increase in all-cause
mortality which ought to be an alarming
fact to anybody interested in whether or
not this
mass vaccination campaign was
ill-advised from the get-go which it
clearly was um
but uh the numbers we're looking at are
conservative because it's still early
yeah yeah and then there is absolutely a
concern about the
safety and if so i would actually you
know
although i never signed that document at
the time we didn't know any we didn't
really know anything at the time and and
that article
was was simply it was actually the
imagination of the editor of the times
into what he was interpreting what was
said and interestingly enough in his
article this is the other thing he never
ever linked to the actual heart document
so people couldn't even see what was
said they were only getting his
interpret his his interpret his
misinterpretation of what was said which
then
you know you then get these other people
on wikipedia then using what and they
themselves put another interpretation of
what his interpretation of what was said
and you get this you get this nonsense
okay so
the interesting thing then is that so i
didn't do anything about it and and you
know
whether it the extent to which it
compromised me
in my expert evidence i i don't know it
may have it may well have done because
people still do look at you know they
still do look wikipedia but there was a
development after that right where i
realized just how
um bad i got a tip off
right about
a set of editing that started to go on
then off with with this
um
uh wikipedia because i think i might
have mentioned it i can't remember when
i mentioned on twitter so obviously some
people did start to look at
people who do this sort of stuff did
start to look at what was going on right
and
what we found out was that
one editor
had tried to at least insert
the following statement that the fenton
denied under oath that that statement of
wikipedia was true
right so that was inserted
that got immediately removed by
so there's one guy
this this uh i mean it's not it's not
doctor because it's actually open it's
not like he's a guy called axe brown who
goes under the wiki editor name of alex
brun right who i found out later was
like
very very well known and he was involved
in the
in you know in the
uh the nonsense put on your um wikipedia
page he was one a key one there and he's
been he's been key in a lot of these
people you know uh malone uh mccullough
he's been involved you know in
he's uh yeah he's trashed he's tried to
trash a lot a lot of people he
then
uh he remembered he he has this rise
he's he's an admin i mean none of these
things that i know anything about what
it is but he's got these admin rights
where he can just you know he he'll just
delete it and if people start putting it
in again he'll just block those people
and that's basically what was happening
so he just deleted that one where
someone just put in a factual statement
which you can see on video there's
actually video evidence of me of me
under oath in the call saying that i
denied i denied that those accusations
in that those accusations
were not true so he just stated a fact
and that that wasn't allowed to be this
was this was not alex brown this was
somebody else attempted something else
simple factual statement that you have
said under oath that you didn't which
had that been in your wikipedia entry
would have caused anyone reading it to
understand ah there's controversy over
whether or not
this
did or did not take place and that you
yourself had said under oath that you
didn't obviously you would not want to
risk perjury if you had in fact signed
this letter so it strongly suggests
something might be wrong with that claim
so so um
that got that got deleted and then there
were a few what then happened was that
there was another guy someone else
actually tried to fix
fix it completely by trying to give the
background of what the heart document
actually
said so he'd gone in there and edited it
by giving the full history about this
this times article and how the times
article got changed over time and and
how it didn't represent what was said in
heart
and basically every every time that was
put up alex brown within seconds within
seconds this guy
even like it doesn't matter any time of
day you know
or if it's if it's like three in the
morning at five in the morning you know
when it gets up you'll have deleted it
right so this was going on so it was
kind of like a war going on and this
went on apparently a few times at which
point alex brown simply blocked that
person
just they just simply block them so
they're not allowed to do they're not
allowed to do anything
for trying to introduce a simply factual
corrective statement
into so and this was
and that's that's the way that's the way
they work
[Music]